CBS News chief Washington correspondent
and Face the Nation anchor John
Dickerson is with us good morning
morning charlie
so did sessions testimony help or hurt
the White House ID helped the White
House because there are three
investigations there's looking into
Russian meddling there's the question of
collusion with the Trump campaign and
it's the question of obstruction
sessions was an obstruction witness he
was there when the president was
evaluating James Comey he was there for
some of these conversations but he
didn't answer any of those questions he
answered questions about his own
behavior defended himself against this
charge he had contacts with the Russians
that's on the collusion question Jeff
Sessions is not the center of the
collusion story so he was strong
forceful that gave sound bites that
showed up on the news and that's what
the White House wants because they want
to be able to say this is about you know
this collusion story there's nothing to
it so let's put this away what's still
out there though of course is the
obstruction story but there was no real
new ground occlusions where he's recused
himself the the the obstruction of
justice is where he's recused himself in
other words any conversation yet with
the president about James Comey or about
the investigation or about anything I
need to do with that he said those are
private conversations with the president
and I'm not going to talk about that
that seemed to frustrate a lot of his
call his former colleagues yesterday he
was at times defiant and defensive they
seemed very angry did we learn anything
at all yesterday they didn't know and
needs to find offensive because he's
fighting charges that are basically all
just rumors and kind of low questions
about you Jeff Sessions and so he had
all access to real anger on that he did
not get as angry about the suggestion
the president might have interfered in
the in the investigation but he gave no
answers because he said the president
might assert executive privilege the
president has not yet but in order that
for that story to continue Congress
would have to hold jeff Sessions in
contempt Republicans are not likely to
do that another big story not to get
lost here as major Garrett reported the
president met with senators and told
them the Republicans centers that their
health care version to repeal Obamacare
is mean that's support so this is a leak
coming from Republican senators by the
way also just as we keep track of
leaking in Washington a little leak out
of this meeting it's extraordinary
because the president has now just put a
really damaging word on the House bill
right Democrats are going to pick up on
this and also the president is judging
this bill he talked about generous kind
and with heart that's not territory that
Republicans want to defend this
bill on they wouldn't defend it on
giving personal freedom helping the
market work better if the president
keeps defining it on those generosity
terms that's playing to a strength that
Democrats have it allows people to talk
about this bill in terms of who it
covers and also Medicaid coverage so
that's not great messaging from the
president thanks John it's good to see
you